this topic applications of
differentiation right what we're going
to increasingly focus on
is places where special things happen so
see this guy here
right it's like oh there's a weird thing
happening at that spot i want to
understand it okay
so we're going to be having a look at
like this page it's quite
like we're going to develop and fill in
this page over like multiple lessons
we're just going to start right at the
top here with the stuff that we're
familiar with
okay so you know how in our table we
said in fact my table
is it's here here we go in our table
we said oh when things are stationary
when your derivative is equal to zero
that's really important right we focus a
lot on that so i want us to fill in a
little more
of what's going on here because there's
more than one kind of stationary point
we kind of alluded to that just now okay
uh yeah it's it's actually not quite a
venn diagram but it's it's like it
so many of the stationary points that we
find
are what we call turning points you've
found these already right so what we
mean is
if you have a look at a particular spot
it's going to have a horizontal
tangent but it also like turns around
like it's it's decreasing and then it's
increasing or
vice versa it might be increasing and
then it might become decreasing so it
turns around
like so so these graphs here
they look like parabolas right so just
as an example as an example
plus or minus x squared these give you
stationary points where things
turn around okay does that make sense
now we saw in even that very first
question
that some stationary points do not do
this increasingly and decreasing
sometimes they increase and then they
just they stop for a minute
and then they just keep on increasing
right so in other words you have
something that looks
somewhat like this
[Music]
wow okay now a perfect example of this
is
x cubed in fact that's what i was trying
to mimic drawing there right
so what's happening is you're increasing
you stop for a moment that's the
stationary part and then you just
keep on increasing you don't turn around
there's no facing the opposite direction
of course i could do this in the reverse
order i could decrease
and then stop and then decrease again
so these guys here are not turning
points
they are still stationary points so
that's why they're in this
inner circle here and just again um and
serene pointed out
as an example of it this is not the only
time that it happens but as an example
x cubed or minus x cubed will give you
this kind of shape
okay now there is one other example
which is there are some really boring
functions that they're just stationary
all the time and we actually drew one
in our previous table right what would
it look like if a function was
always stationary the answer is it's a
linear function right that's very
correct well it's just a horizontal line
yeah a linear
function like this um importantly it's
not
it's not going up linear or not going
down linear it's got to be horizontal
it's got to be parallel
to the x-axis so you know if you've got
y equals to
well actually if you have y equals to
any constant number 0 1 2 3
negative 1 2 3 or whatever y equals a
constant
you will get this kind of behavior okay
now i actually want you to think because
like even though this is going to be our
focus for the next little bit these are
the stationary points we're interested
in
there are other kinds of functions that
you know about
which for example they turn around even
though
they're not stationary how many of you
have your notes
from last topic still in your current
book i know some of you moved on but how
many of you got the notes there anyone
what was that last stop is graphing
techniques
okay so here's what i want you to do i
want you to think about what this guy
looks like
right what does this function look like
do you remember this guy
yeah it's this bouncy v looking thing
right so you can go ahead and you can
draw
something in like so okay now i hope you
can see
this is a function that well think about
the word right
does it turn and the answer is totally
turns right it's
it's decreasing and then it's increasing
okay
the difference is though we don't call
it a stationary point because
it's sort of in this category right you
can't actually find a derivative
at that spot where it turns around okay
so we call this guy the reason why it
does this
behavior is it's called a piecemeal
function it actually changes
from one side to the other side right in
fact
this is really shorthand for minus x
over here and positive x okay